regardez ce que je ne recevoir ici c'est
le tout nouveau rock faune rock phone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5-0 active couleurs ok ça c'est petit
ventilateur qu'on va mettre au dos
j'adore le packaging au tournant d'école
un peu particulier un chez asus là
dessus avec le roquefort republic of
gamers rog 5 kw et noir wow oh la vache
jadore jadore jadore la caisse que j'ai
ça je vais voir quoi une petite coque
des autocollants away ça c'est ça c'est
trop trop classe j'adore est ici
roquefort il fait son poids de notre
côté ce n'est pas surprenant faveur
c'est surprenant en fait ce design comme
ça c'est très atypique et ses codes
blanc je suis pas habitué mais j'aime
bien on a déjà retrouvé un peu ses codes
chez asus plus sûr du pc j'aime bien ce
bleu comme ça ça c'est supra premium
republic of gamers avec les petites
flèches
donc tout ça ça va venir ça lui mais on
va pouvoir venir effectivement choisir
la couleur en fonction de ses équipes
c'est à peu près la même chose qu'on
avait avant le module photo avec trois
capteurs le petit flash journaleux
trouva pour le micro ici je le trouve un
peu épais mais ça me dérange pas c'est
pareil les finitions elles sont super
belle bouton de volume pour venir là lui
mais ça ça peut être un micro je suppose
ici j'ai une prise jack ça c'est cool
j'ai de la recharge en usb cg un micro
ici là j'ai découvert mon tiroir de
cartes sim là je peux bien branché mon
ventilateur et des accessoires de l'usbc
du coup si tu parviens déportés
recharger redis ça me l'a allumé
directement
[Musique]
après les joutes tout faire ça à vrai
dire elle parle j'ai pas vu la fiche
technique encore c'est vraiment de la
première découverte en c'est parti vous
le voyez ici vous avez la caméra qui
planque est juste là c'est vraiment
différent par rapport à retrouver sur
l'ensemble du marché vous avez des
écrans qui vont venir beaucoup plus haut
avec des caméras intégrées ici asus je
pense pour l'expérience de jeu a fait le
choix effectivement de ne pas succomber
à cette tentation là tant que les
caméras ne peuvent pas être sous l'écran
et bien elles n'y sont pas on a donc
cette grande caméra ici on a ce haut
parleur qui est planqué là qui je pense
va je vais aussi pour la stéréo
il y en a on le voit en effet regardez
là en bas pas si vous aviez vous en
rendre compte vous avez le deuxième haut
parleurs qui est planqué là ce qui fait
que vous avez deux haut parleurs en
façade et qui vont venir jouer pour
l'image stéréo et on va cesser sa dans
quelques instants aussi les airs trigger
qui sont juste là haut ils sont ici les
intrigues heures en fait un air de fête
voire y est entrée dans l'univers de
akira dans le vaisseau spatial
battez-vous côte à côte contre les
ennemis une fois la mission terminée
mettez le masque facial exclusif pour
créer la carte d'identité ouvrez la vue
mondial drogue
moi j'adore choisissez le design
l'emballage du téléphone alors moi c'est
ça jadore jadore jadore l'expérience
allait vraiment super super super cool
continue ou away ce qui veut dire que là
j'ai une vraie expérience c'est génial
j'adore l'expérience alice raucoules le
boulot qu'ils ont fait là dessus et
akira voie générale plaît je vois ça
vous fait vivre l'expérience est génial
tourner landscape mode
[Applaudissements]
les vibrations c'est absolument
incroyable
j'adore
[Musique]
oh
je suis hyper fall
faire les vibrations c'est dingue j'ai
moi qui vibre d'el-malah pour le coup je
vais vous dire c'est vraiment anxieuses
l'expérience à l'épaule vous ouvrez
votre téléphone vous arriver là dessus
l'expérience est absolument dingue
j'adore regardez-moi ça le boulot de
asus là dessus ces officines aux
objectifs
je les adore la réalité augmentée comme
ça c'est magnifique
vous ouvrez vous avez une expérience
comme ça c'est génial j'aime bien ça ça
j'aime bien ok photo yes
j'adore fait partie de drogue ça
l'expérience est absolument incroyable
vous arrivez vous ouvrez votre téléphone
vous retrouvez avec votre boîte qui est
vivante avec akira vous avez toute
l'expérience ça vous met dedans
directement le boulot là dessus café
asus
il est génial sur ce rock 25 il n'y
avait pas eu de rock funk 4 il ya eu
rope phone trois rocs 25,4 c'est un
chiffre qui porte malheur en asie donc
on va pas le retrouver et rock phone 5
directement on se fait le test
il arrive très rapidement qui ne fait
plus les écoles namouric right on la
retrouve vraiment tout ce qu'on connaît
et ce qu'on aime sur le roc phone
l'expérience allait vraiment très cool
il ya deux bénéfices avec l'hérault
actifs couleurs le premier c'est que
vous avez un ventilateur qui va venir
tourner et qui va permettre de dissiper
la chaleur donc de refroidir votre
smartphone et sur des grandes parties de
gaming c'est vachement bien et puis
surtout ce qu'ils ont fait ce talent et
sait que vous avez des boutons de chaque
côté donc ça vous rajoute des boutons
vous avez en tout 18 boutons pour venir
jouer différents ici entre les airs
trigger autres ce que vous allez avoir
sur l'aéronautique couleurs et toutes
les manips directement fin c'est
vraiment vraiment intéressant et puis
surtout derrière c'est pouvoir venir
affiché en plus ici les couleurs de
votre team
enfin ya pas mal de choses que je vais
le lire personnalisé et vous retrouver
en plus juste ici en dessous une prise
jack pour venir jouer plus facilement
vous avez soit celle là soit celle là
donc lorsque vous jouez vous et votre
prix dia qui est juste en dessous dans
sa course a vraiment vraiment vraiment
pratique et puis autre point qui est
extrêmement pratique vous garder ici
votre prise usb c'est qui est ouverte ça
vous évite devient branchez-le à devenir
tous branchés à côté que ça vienne poser
problème pour le tenir en main parce que
lorsque vous jouez vous le tenez comme
ça et bien si vous avez une prise jack
qui vous branche en plus ici blue peut
plus tenir vous êtes comme ça vous êtes
en mettez donc ça vient vraiment
maximiser l'expérience ça c'est un petit
accessoire mais je trouve très très cool
entre accessoires qui vraiment pour moi
un des indispensables
c'est lui là c'est le coup d'oeil 3
gamepad hop hop c'est quand même
vachement clash j'ai quand même pas mal
de commande ici avec tous les différents
boutons que je pouvais venir retrouver
et personnalisée est assignée de plus en
plus on est ici là à l'arrière et je
peux venir même le mec crise s'ils
commencent à se positionne sa bascule
c'est là je pense
yes ça me fait une vraie manette de jeu
pour venir jouer de la recharge sur le
dessus
donc ça il fallait plus on m'a souhaité
rester très rapidement et je vous donne
mon retour très vite et puis dernier
accessoire qui est assez marrant ce sont
les rucks et ratent deux corps sont des
petits écouteurs vous allez avoir pour
venir écouter pour pouvoir interagir
pour venir discuter directement avec vos
amis ou votre team surtout on va déjà à
erez audio packaging est toujours être
plus très très bien les écouteurs
regarder ça l'a alors attendez on essaie
de sortir ça sent tout arracher on a les
écouteurs avec les petites ailettes on a
ici à l'intérieur
différentes tailles d'embouts pour vos
oreilles on va avoir différentes tailles
del est une fois de plus pour adapter
également à la morphologie de chacun on
a de la prise jack jack cdu 3.5 donc ça
c'est pas mal aussi discorde certifié
donc pour tout ce qui va être gimme là
aussi vous avez un produit qui a d'être
très très cool tout ça on se le test
très très rapidement je vous fais mon
retour sur la chaîne on vous invite dès
maintenant à venir vous abonner comme ça
vous serez tous il voyait ya un
écosystème il ya plein de choses je
rentrais plus dans le détail pour vous
parler effectivement de ce nouveau
smartphone qui est le roc phone 5 plein
de choses à dire sur la charge sur la
puissance sur le taux de
rafraîchissement de l'écran enfin ça
c'est vraiment bien donc je vous en
parle aussi très très très rapidement
donnez-moi donnez-moi donnez-moi
donnez-moi quelques jours le temps de
continuer à jouer sur le roc von finck
moi je trouve très sympa je trouve très
cool j'aime beaucoup la proposition le
fait d'avoir ce design qui est un petit
peu revu et corrigé d'avoir ses
nouvelles couleurs ses plus belles
couleurs blanches en tout cas qui vient
coller à l'esprit du zéphyr us dont je
vous ai déjà parlé ya quelques temps
j'aime beaucoup une fois de plus aussi
chez asus il est un petit peu lourd mais
fatalement il ya deux batteries 3000
millions terreur et audrey d'ici
quelques jours mon retour complet sur ce
smartphone en vous expliquant la fiche
technique en vous expliquant ce qui est
bien ce qui l'est moins
il faut encore un petit peu de temps
pour finir complètement de l'apprivoiser
d'ailleurs vous avez vu si vous avez
fait gaffe entre moment je en train de
tourner tout de suite et moment où j'ai
commencé à tourner il ya quelques jours
pour finir de le déballer complètement
et 2,2 tout va moi j'aime bien ce cette
proposition asus plus toujours des
smartphones hyper performant hyper
puissant vous avez ce qu'il faut
derrière le fait d'avoir en plus cet
effet qu on retrouve vraiment dans
l'univers gaming de asus vous pouvez
venir paramétrer pas mal de choses
on s'est vraiment cool voilà j'aime bien
j'aime bien le propos et si vous êtes
fan de gaming si vous aimez vraiment les
smartphones de galim le vrai smartphone
de gaming pas uniquement un très bon
processeur avec de la ram et du stockage
vraiment une recherche au niveau du
gaming derrière c'est à dire d'un point
de vue logiciel d'un point de vue humain
rien comme on optimise la température
comme on optimise l'expérience de charge
et en optimisent tout est bien là dessus
a vu c'est vraiment extrêmement fort je
sais pas si vous avez suivi mais c'est
vachement intéressant ce que nous fait
asus cette année vous n'avez pas un roc
phone vous avez trois rocs faut nous
avait le rock 25
vous avez le rock 25 pros et vous avez
le rock phone 5 ultimate on parlera des
specs dans la vidéo test où on va tout
détailler toute l'espagne et compagnie
mais là je voudrais vous parler des
tarifs vous avez plusieurs
configurations et surtout celle des
smartphones qui vont arriver à des
périodes un peu échelonnée on va déjà
commencer par l'europe 25 qui va arriver
en premier
vous avez trois versions 8 gigas de ram
128 go de stockage qui coûte 799 euros
vous avez une version 12 giga de ram 256
go de stockage à 899 euros et vous avez
une version 16 giga de ram 16 giga de
ram 256 go de stockage à 999 euros
ça c'est pour le modèle normal et vous
avez modèle pro avec 16 giga de ram 512
go de stockage à 1199 euros sans oublier
modèle ultimate le modèle ultimate il va
jusqu'à 18 g 18 h drame c'est démentiel
plus 512 julia de stockage 1299 euros ce
qui va arriver en premier c'est le rock
phone 5,16 plus 256 giga de stockage qui
va arriver en tout premier donc c'est le
modèle à 999 euros va arriver ensuite
mi-avril le modèle 12 plus de 156 et
ensuite début mais vous aurez modèle lui
de plus en 28 ce n'est pas une volonté
d' injuste de pousser avec du 16 giga
drame d'abord puis du 12 + 18 cd
problème si vous voulez au niveau des
composants à cause du comité des
problèmes de main d'oeuvre de
disponibilité et ce qu'ils on dispose
tout de suite c'est uniquement le saisit
au drame le reste arrivera ensuite
manière échelonnée entre avril et le
mois de mai donc si vous voulez dès
maintenant le tout premier iphone d'asus
et bien je vous mets un lien en bas dans
la description avec cia drame si vous
voulez un modèle 12 8 gigas de ram qui
vous coûteront un peu moins cher il va
falloir un petit peu s'armer de patience
on en parle d'ici quelques jours des
bisous de la mort ou pour les soins de
vous ciao